here's an unusual man an Italian who
doesn't sing
he's one of this year's nominees for
outstanding performance by an actor he's
famous for his brilliant love scenes
with some of the world's most beautiful
actresses and I think anyone who plays
opposite Sophia Loren and convinces an
audience that he's a homosexual deserves
a nomination and with him as a star of
TV films and posters she's been on so
many magazine covers she has to stamp
the date on her Ford so people will
recognize her in public has been so much
written about or even Rona Barrett had
nothing left to say ladies and gentlemen
a fantastic duo Farrah Fawcett majors
and Marcello Mastroianni
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
your special way and now I have my
special night being here with you thank
you thank you you're very kind thank you
for everybody the nominees for
outstanding achievement in film editing
are Michael Kahn for Close Encounters of
the Third Kind Walter March for Julian
Walter Hanuman and Angela Ross for
Smokey and abandon all it's hers sorry
Marcia Lucas and Rita Chu for Star Wars
William Reynolds for the turning point
and the winner miss falsities okay the
winners are Paul Hirsch Marshall Lucas
and Richard Childress Star Wars this is
a great honor especially in light of the
excellence of the competition this year
on a personal note I'd like to thank
Brian De Palma for believing me and
believing in me for so many years and
I'd like to express my admiration for my
colleagues Marsha and Richard who are
not only great editors they're great
people
we had a wonderful hard-working staff
Todd buckle hide Jay miracle Mike
kitchens and Pam aloof
we had an inspired sound editor and Ben
Burtt one of the most knowledgeable
produces in the business and Gary Kurtz
and last but most significantly we had a
director who apart from his many other
obvious talents is himself a fine editor
George Lucas thank you George thank you
[Applause]
[Music]